[Music]
welcome
foolish mortals to the first ever
halloween special on the monster maze
channel
today we cover the dark secrets of a
small
remote oasis a place that in the actual
game
isn't really all that dark and scary to
be honest oh really it's actually quite
a nice place
a tiny sun-drenched paradise a place to
get a good tan
enjoy yourself a tropical drink and just
chillax at the sea
is that even a word people still use
chillax i don't know i have a hard time
keeping up with the trends of vocabulary
anyway while this place isn't really all
that haunting or scary
we're gonna make it scary with a
haunting soundtrack
dark atmosphere over analyzing and
overthinking the narrative to fabricate
a spooky story
and turn this cutesy little game into
the horror fest it was always destined
to be
the wind waker's great sea is home to a
number of very interesting and
mysterious islands
small leftovers of a time when hyrule
was still a prosperous land before it
was wiped out by the great flood set in
motion by the gods to deal with
ganondorf's invasion of the kingdom
during the catastrophe the surviving
population fled to the mountaintops to
start their lives anew
and stories of the former hylian capital
slowly turned to legend
while exploring the great sea you might
have stumbled upon this
remote little island known as the
private oasis
on your first visit you will quickly
discover that the island is someone's
private property
you can walk around the premises freely
however trying to enter the cabana
itself results in a disembodied voice
rudely commanding you to leave
and that quote this cabana belongs to
the master
and the master alone a sign on the front
lawn informs you that the house belongs
to a certain mrs mary
a teacher who resides on windfall island
when we pay her a visit she seems to be
just an ordinary person a responsible
albeit a bit eccentric woman with a love
for education and a strong devotion to
spreading joy
after some brief conversations it
becomes clear that besides her life's
mission of shaping the minds of the
youth on windfall island she also has an
obsession with collecting jewelry
and in particular joy pendants butterfly
shaped necklaces which are said to
spread joy to those who obtained them
interestingly enough these pendants are
mostly found in the game's dungeons
and in the pockets of bokoblins one of
the pig-like monsters
roaming the land after receiving her
first joy pendant as a birthday gift
from some of the kids outside
she states that she is overjoyed but her
cravings don't stop there
and she makes it clear that she'd really
like to have 20 of them if you adhere to
a request and gift her an additional 20
joy pendants
wait hold on i'm no mathematical genius
but
i believe that's 21 mrs mary what kind
of scam are you running here
anyway after she receives her 21 joy
pendants
she rewards you with the cabana deed yes
she trades you 20 joy pendants which are
valued around
20 rupees apiece for her private island
i
seriously need to reconsider the
mortgage on my apartment with the cabana
deed now in your possession
you have just become the new owner of
the private oasis
awesome let us set sail for our new
abode and enjoy the luxuries
after presenting the cabana deed at the
door the voice heard from inside the
house
promptly shifts its tone and is
delighted to hear that the place now has
a new master
upon entering the house we are greeted
with a cozy atmosphere
a warm fireplace expensive pottery
sitting on the top shelves
a lawn chair a bath not bad not bad
indeed
but one might notice immediately that
you are alone
inside the house so then whose voice do
we keep hearing at the door
as it turns out this cabana isn't empty
it's occupied by
something something we cannot see the
room houses a total of three wooden
cutouts of a butler
two mirrored versions and one where the
butler is dressed as a maid
additionally he is also depicted on both
sides of the front door
the servant of this cozy cabin isn't a
real person
now of course when playing the game most
of us don't really think any more of it
this is zelda after all we're used to
some really weird stuff so
whatever but if we stop and think about
this situation it's actually
rather creepy a lonely cabana in the
middle of nowhere tended to by a
disembodied voice which seems to emanate
from within
almost as if the house itself is alive
pair this with the rather unsettling
wooden cutouts and the place subtly
feels
a lot less serene although the voice
itself is friendly towards link once he
is deemed a new master
i can't help but shake the feeling that
something's always watching you
imagine taking a bath in this place with
these strange shapes standing in the
corner
seemingly staring right at you because
of the strangeness of the situation
theories about this butler have
suggested that he might actually be
a ghost a spirit who's tied to this
particular house
cursed to serve the cabana's master for
all eternity
although the game itself implies that
the physical form of the butler is the
front door of the abode
there are some things that suggest
otherwise if he really was
just a door as if the aspect of a
sentient door wasn't already strange
enough
but then what's the purpose of the other
cutouts
secondly we know for a fact that the
butler is able to interact with
objects on the island for instance after
solving one of the slide puzzles on the
wall
he will set up a new one for link to
solve but before doing so he will ask
link to vacate the cabana so he can set
it up
almost as if he doesn't want link to see
how he does it out of fear of freaking
him out
on top of that after entering the cabana
for the first time
the wooden sign outside on the front
lawn changes
again the idea of a front door achieving
consciousness is already out of the
ordinary but
the fact that it can manipulate the
environment suggests that the door
and the cutouts are simply stand-ins a
way to
personify this otherworldly servant but
if you thought the mystery ended here
you are mistaken this rabbit hole goes
much further and by rabbit hole i mean
the one found
inside the fireplace
[Music]
on the ceiling of the cabana we find a
large lever or
switch which we can trigger with the
grappling hook doing so will douse the
flames of the fireplace and reveal an
entrance to the cabana's basement
once we enter we see that this place is
quite the opposite
of the cozy atmosphere found above cold
grey walls
the floor flooded with water up the
ankle's height rats scouring around and
drain pipes spaced alongside the walls
hinting that this is some sort of a
sewer system upon exploring further
however we find that this place seems to
serve as something more than just a
sewer
there's switches that open various gates
ladders leading down deeper into the
ground
and tight crawl spaces snaking through
the inner structure
some rooms have no rhyme or reason
frequent dead ends
rooms filled with nothing more than just
some pottery and tunnels which loop back
to the same location
not only is this place a maze but it's
big much bigger than the cabana itself
and seems to stretch across
and down the entire mountain peak the
house sits upon if this really was just
a sewer then it's one hell of an
overkill for such a small island
inhabited by only one resident
but this place has more in store for us
than just rats though
this quote-unquote sewer goes down deep
so deep in fact that we eventually start
seeing different layers of the earth and
even the fossilized remains of long dead
shellfish buried deep inside the rocks
but that's not all something else is
lurking
deep on the ground waiting for us
[Applause]
if we drop down one of the holes we are
greeted by two re-dads who reside in
this small
underground chamber okay real talk by
the way despite the fact that i was
already around 16 years old when i
played this game
this must have been one of the biggest
jump scares of any zelda game i've ever
played you see
i visited this location pretty early on
in the game and
at that point i didn't even know redads
were going to be in the game
not to mention the awful sound they make
when they lock eyes with you
up until then the game had been nothing
but a lighthearted little adventure
and i didn't imagine this game would
have anything to offer in terms of
disturbing elements like the ones found
in ocarina of time or majora's mask
now i'm pretty sure this is recognizable
for a lot of you veteran zelda players
out there
as you might know in every 3d zelda game
prior to breath of the wild
fall damage could be mitigated by
holding the control stick forward
causing link to roll
this is a very useful way to avoid
unnecessary damage so as a zelda player
you are inclined to always hold forward
when jumping down
it's kind of been burned into your
memory so i did just that i dropped down
the hole
rolled forward right into the lap of one
of these monstrosities who immediately
started screeching
i don't remember my exact reaction back
then but i'm pretty sure there's still a
hole in the ceiling of my parents old
house somewhere
anyway back to the story now what in
tingle's name and all that is holy are
two
reanimated corpses doing in the basement
of a remote oasis
as zelda wiki states correctly they
mainly appear in the earth temple as
well as the ghost ship
the savage labyrinth ganon's tower and
unusually in the sewer tunnels of the
private oasis
unusually is right all the other
locations mentioned make sense when it
comes to housing redads
they are either places infested by
ganondorf's influence
a test for the hero or in the case of
the ghost ship some sort of a cursed
place with a supernatural presence
if we manage to get past the redact and
venture further into the final stretch
of the sewers we get a clue as to why
these monsters may reside here
in the final room we find sort of an
altar two decorative pillars with the
same kind of swirl pattern we find in
the earth temple
and two pedestals one with the symbol of
the wind's requiem and the other with
the symbol of the triforce
conducting the wind's requiem will
reveal a chest with either a triforce
piece
or in the case of the original on the
gamecube a chart leading to the triforce
piece
i think the fact that we find a piece of
the holy relic here
suggests that this place wasn't meant to
serve as a sewer but rather as a hiding
spot for a piece of the triforce of
courage
and the read ads may have been placed
here on purpose as a protection
waiting for an unexpecting visitor to
venture into their domain
to prevent the triforce piece from
falling into the hands of the unworthy
now some may suggest that the re-deaths
have simply been ganondorf's doing but
i find that hard to believe if we take
some inspiration from celtic's ideas
about this topic
it becomes obvious that ganondorf isn't
the only one capable of creating
re-deads
in fact in the case of the ones found in
the earth temple it's undeniable that
the re-deads have resided here long
before
ganondorf invaded this holy site proof
of this lies within the fact that the
giant statue inside the central mirror
chamber
unmistakably resembles a giant redead
and celtic makes a strong case that it
wasn't ganondorf but rather
the royal family with the assistance of
the shika who placed the undead here to
act as guardians for the temple
and it makes sense the hylians built the
temple after all it used to be a sacred
place of worship where the sage of earth
would pray to uphold the master sword's
power to seal the darkness
the former sage of earth loruto states
that she offered her prayers here for
over an age but was killed by ganondorf
when he broke free from his seal
this would mean that the earth temple
including the giant statue of the
re-dead were built
long before the great flood and likely
soon after the events of ocarina of time
furthermore the king of red lion states
that after the hero of time departed
from the land of hyrule
which describes the events of link
getting sent back seven years into the
child branch of the timeline the
triforce of kurds departed from the hero
and split into eight pieces
which were hidden across the land by
that definition the sewers underneath
the cabana were also built long before
the great flood and it's likely that the
cabana itself was built on top of it a
long time
after the reason why i think this is
because the architecture of the cabana
itself has a very strong resemblance to
the houses found on outside island
link's hometown which wasn't founded
until the people of hyrule fled to the
mountaintops in order to survive the
great flood
it's quite obvious that the original
builder slash owner of the cabana
knew about the existence of the
underground maze and may have even known
what was down there
but instead of sealing the entrance
completely they hid it away behind a
secret entrance inside the fireplace
with that in mind could the mysterious
ghostly butler be the original owner of
the cabana
who devoted himself to protecting the
secret lurking beneath his house even in
death
it would explain why he's so intent on
keeping trespassers off the property
however as not to draw suspicion of this
lone empty oasis
the cabana must have a living inhabitant
a master for the butler to serve
which brings us back to mrs mary it's
obvious that she isn't the first to own
the cabana
when receiving the cabana deed the game
remarks that the deed itself
looks old mrs mary herself cannot be
more than 40
maybe 50 years old and her statue in the
gallery states that she's been a teacher
on windfall for the past
20 years it's unknown if mary actually
knows about the basement
but she must at least know about the
ghostly butler
something she never talks about to link
although she hides behind a persona of a
joyful
eccentric teacher with a love for kids
mrs mary
is definitely hiding secrets nobody on
windfall island knows that she owns the
cabana
and i mean nobody this is evident from
one of the photographs found in lenzo's
personal gallery
he states that when he was younger he
used to travel the great seas to take
pictures of interesting locations
some of his pictures include the ghost
ship one of the triangle island statues
the forsaken fortress
outset island and the cabana when asking
lenzo about the photograph
he says that he is certain that this is
someone's private cabana
meaning he doesn't know who it belongs
to not only that but mrs mary lets it
slip on certain occasions that she is
absolutely
loaded with cash we all know full well
that being a teacher
isn't exactly the most well-paid job in
the world so
how did she get to be so incredibly rich
and
why would she hide her fortunes from the
rest of windfall
including the fact that she owns her own
private oasis
some people on windfall speculate and
gossip about it but they seem to be
oblivious otherwise
even to link mrs mary never discloses
how and why she came into possession of
her fortune
what is she hiding i mean she seems
pretty eager to just hand off her
property to link for some pendants worth
a mere
400 rupees in total she claims it's
because she's tired of traveling and
wants to spend her remaining days on
windfall but
just giving it away like that seems a
bit odd
either she really has no more incentive
to visit the oasis
or she's passing some kind of burden to
someone else
riches usually don't come for free i
mean we've seen that happen in twilight
princess where giovanni sold his soul
for a great fortune
the cabana deed itself translates to the
following
villa land entitlement admit ownership
marry admit ownership huh as in
sign here you're literally making a deal
also note that the term admit and own
are not the same
to admit something means being allowed
to enter which is by no means having
rightful possession
the cabana doesn't really belong to mrs
mary
it never has it belongs to an entity
which has watched over this island for
who knows how long but the cabana must
have a master
it could explain why mrs mary is so
obsessed with collecting joy pendants in
particular
perhaps she is trying to remedy
something darker
something attached to her following her
she paid a hefty price for her life of
riches
and luxury she wanted to move on and
live on windfall island
but the cabana kept calling her unable
to escape from her responsibility
she eventually found a young new
candidate to satisfy
the cabana
or she just endlessly solved the sliding
puzzle inside the cabana which the
butler pays you handsomely for
rinse and repeat
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you